vous l'aurez compris pour moi les
quelques et je place entre guillemets
accord trouvés sont des écrans de fumée
qui masquent le fait que l'exécutif
choisit de s'exonérer de toute
validation parlementaire à l'Assemblée
par le 493 utilisé je le rappelle sans
aucun débat en Science Publique ce qui
est nouveau par rapport à la pratique
historique du 493 et n'est pas conforme
à l'esprit de la Constitution et au
Sénat par l'absence de prise en compte
de nos votes car la réalité c'est
qu'aucun des principaux votes du Sénat
n'est retenu aucun des dispositifs
fiscaux en faveur de la transmission du
patrimoine et du Logement pas de
maintien du PTZ je l'ai évoqué pas de
ciblage des aides pour l'électricité pas
de fonds d'urgence climatique pour les
collectivités territoriales pas de prise
en compte des demandes du Sénat sur les
dotations aux collectivités la hausse de
laadgf reste à 100 millions d'euros et
l'aide d'urgence au départ
ne sera pas de 100 million d'euros pas
un centime de quôte carbone ne sera mis
au service des autorités organisatrices
de mobilité en province on décelle même
en examinant précisément le 493 la
volonté du gouvernement de ne pas être
constructif en effet par le 493 vous
revenez sur les dizaines d'avis
favorables que monsieur le ministre vous
avez vous-même à ce banc devant nous
rendu encore une fois quel
en cette circonstance la crédibilité de
la parole politique et du gouvernement
dans ces
conditions ce sont en effet les propres
engagements du gouvernement qui sont
reniés je vais prendre un exemple la
commission des finances et le Sénat à sa
suite ont appliqué la lo de
programmation des finances publiques
tout juste voté pour borner à 3 ans
jusqu'en 2026 les nouvell niches fiscale
et pourtant dans le 493 vous revenez sur
la majorité de ces born
qui sont pourtant des engagements que
vous avez vous-même pris à travers un
autre 493 sur la LPFP c'est à ni plus
rien comprendre ce non respect des
engagements pris est encore plus
flagrant s'agissant de la trajectoire
d'emploi du PLF où l'objectif de
stabilité de la LPFP est piétiné autant
que les amendements du Sénat visant
pourtant à produire un effort sur les
emplois des opérateurs notamment enfin
c'est un peu la scrise sur le gâteau le
texte du 493 pose d'importants problèmes
constitutionnels le gouvernement
introduit dans le texte en nouvelle
lecture des dispositions entières sans
lien direct avec les dispositions encore
en discussion qui n'auront donc été
examiné par aucune des assemblées je dis
bien aucune des assemblées à l'article 5
qu des siè une réécriture globale du
dispositif Madelin à l'article 16 qu a
une réforme de la TGAP d'une grande
technicité qui n'a rien à voir avec la
TGAP en outre m dont traitait pourtant
initialement l'article à l'article 25
bis une réforme jamais discuté de la
compensation des compétences exercées
par les région en matière de formation
professionnelle continue par ailleurs le
gouvernement se laisse de plus en plus
de marge fiscal hors la vue du Parlement
en violation de la compétence fiscale du
législateur à l'article 11 vous allez
vous autoriser à augmenter de 1 milliard
les les assises sur le gaz payés par les
ménages français à l'article 16 sexè
vous déplafonnez complètement les tarifs
de sûreté et de sécurité de la taxe sur
le transport aérien des passagers enfin
et je l'ai évoqué lors de l'examen des
articles non rattachés vous
réintroduisez l'article 44 sur les
reports de crédit qui supprime sans
justification précise tout plafond de
report de crédit dit pour désormais non
pas 12 programmes comme dans le
programme initial non pas 37 programmes
comme dans le premier 493 mais sur 43
programmes budgétaires distincts je
rappelle monsieur le ministre que la
LOLF impose pour ces report un plafond
par programme et une justification
précise c'est le principe même de
l'annuité budgétaire et donc le principe
même de l'autorisation parlementaire qui
est ici piétinée je je ne peux pas finir
ma présentation de cette nouvelle
lecture sans évoquer la caricature que
constitue l'article visant les
Fédération Internationale olympique qui
est un condensé de tous les défauts que
je viens d'évoquer il est donc désormais
acté tenez-vous bien que le gouvernement
réintroduit dans le 493 le paradis
fiscal pour la FIFA excusez du peu pas
d'impôt sur les sociétés pas de
cotisation foncière des entreprises pas
pas d'impôt sur le revenu pour ses
salariés et ce au profit d'une
organisation privée qui brasse pourtant
des milliards d'euros cette disposition
monsieur le ministre n'a pas été votée à
l'Assemblée nationale ni en première ni
en nouvelle lecture et je rappelle
qu'elle a été supprémé ici au Sénat à
l'unanimité cette réintroduction par le
gouvernement n'est pas un manque de
prise en compte du Parlement elle ne
pose pas la question des éventuels
apports du Sénat elle est une véritable
provocation non seulement pour le Sénat
mais pour les Français une décision
particulièrement grave tant elle manque
de mesure d'équité et de justice alors
je vous pose la question monsieur le
ministre pourquoi cet aveuglement
coupable et cet acharnement
forcenné ma conclusion parce qu'il en
faut bien une monsieur le ministre ne
vous étonnera donc pas la commission des
finances propose et a proposé ce matin à
voté une large deer la question
préalable en nouvelle lecture sur ce
projet de loi de finan pour